avanthier je vous ai dit que toute
politique était un
choix il faut que ce choix vous le
fassiez en connaissance de cause puisque
vous êtes des citoyens c'est-à-dire que
le 5 décembre vous serez responsable
vous seul de l'avenir de notre
pays c'est donc pour vous informer pour
vous éclairer le mieux possible que j'ai
demandé à un journaliste dont vous
connaissez l'indépendance d'esprit de me
poser les questions que peut-être vous
vous posez à
vous-même ce journaliste c'est Roger
Louis et bien monsieur mitteran ce ce
journaliste et ce citoyen a écoute avec
attention ce que vous avez dit dans
votre première intervention ainsi que ce
qu'on dit les autres candidats
d'ailleurs
il y a une première chose qui m'a frappé
c'est que contrairement aux autres vous
ne vous êtes pas
présenté même le général de Gaulle a dit
vous me connaissez suffisamment pour je
pas besoin de le faire
est-ce volontaire de votre part pourquoi
je répugne un peu à tout ce qui pourrait
paraître être une exhibition
personnelle et d'autre part le débat est
d'une telle ampleur politique qu'il me
paraissait inutile d' ins sur ce que
pouvait être mon passé surtout mon passé
lointain voilà peut-être ce qui m'a
guidé mais si vous voulez je ne vous
demande pas
euh sur le plan anecdotique évidemment
de raconter votre vie je ne pense pas
que ce soit mais ce que ce qui
m'intéresserait c'est de savoir vous
êtes aujourd'hui l'unique candidat de la
gauche c'est de savoir au travers disons
d'un minimum de choses de votre vie
comment vous êtes devenu cet homme de
gauche qu'est-ce qui fait que vous êtes
un homme de bouche oui je crois qu'en
effet votre question est utile à vrai
dire mes origines celles de ma famille
se limite à qu provinces de France et
aussi loin qu'on puisse remonter dans le
temps on y retrouve mes ancêtres c'est
le Berri le Limousin le Poitou la
charante mais je me sens du pays de mon
enfance c'est bien normal et le pays de
mon enfance c'est la charante au confin
de l'angou et de la Saintonge
je crois que cette province a un
caractère particulier fait de
nuances de tranquillité d'esprit de
patience et je crois que j'en ai tiré
quelques profit surtout que j'ai vécu
dans une famille où l'on éta très
nombreux nous avons été élevés 10
enfants h frères et sœurs et deux
cousins germains dont le père avait été
à la guerre de
1914 mon père n'avait pas de fortune ça
donc était difficile mais mais rien ne
remplacera cette ce début de vie heureux
que nous avons eu tous ensemble cela m'a
marqué puis l'enseignement peut-être de
mes parents qui étaient des gens stricts
mais
bon de mon père que
tirerais-je l'enseignement de la
tolérance et puis aussi celui du
patriotisme j'ai d'ailleurs eu un autre
aspect dans mon enfance car j'ai
beaucoup vécu à la campagne chez mes
grands-parents maternels
c'était dans un coin perdu du Sud de la
Charente tout près de la
Dordogne alors là j'ai j'ai éprouvver la
merveilleuse découverte la merveilleuse
découverte de la
liberté dans un coin éloigné de tout
village sans eau sans électricité on
pourrait se croire avant le delluge mais
non c'était dans mon enfance avec le
cheval et la voiture pour aller faire
les courses cela m'a marqué profondément
peut-être aussi est-ce que cela m'a
donné un certain goût de la
solitude liberté solitude tout ça c'est
un peu théorique quel âge avez-vous 49
ans 49 ans donc la guerre
3945 est arrivée en pleine période bien
comme tous ceux de ma génération je suis
né pendant une guerre
et une autre guerre m'acueillli au-delà
de mes 20
ans j'en ai forcément tiré des
expériences majeures pour
moi la première peut-être la plus
importante a été celle de la captivité
car j'ai été prisonnier de guerre
j'avais été blessé j'ai été donc pris
dans un hôpital où l'OM me soigné
emmené en Allemagne et là j'ai vécu des
moments extraordinaires j'ai vu se
défaire puis se refaire une société
pendant les premiers mois à qui
appartenait la direction de nos camps
bah au plus fort au plus brutaux 30 35
hommes entassés sur un flan de colline
on apporte les vivres qui les
aura 6 mois plus tard c'était le
contraire avec une minutie
extraordinaire on se partageait la boule
de pain ou la soupe de rutabaga et
c'était les meilleurs et les plus justes
qu'il faisait alors ce passage presque
mécanique d'une société injuste où
régnait le plus fort jusqu'à une société
de justice m'a beaucoup impressionné et
je continue de m'y rapporter constamment
dans ma vie politique j'ajoute que les
camarades de cette époque sont restés
pour moi les meilleurs amis de ma vie
est-ce que ça vous paraît une une assez
bonne définition de d'une société régie
par la gauche en tout cas j'ai appris un
certain nombre de choses en particulier
la lutte nécessaire pour la justice et
la force finale et souveraine de la
justice ce qui fait que je suis un homme
de gauche optimiste je crois toujours
qu'on doit gagner seulement je vous
parler de la guerre puisque c'est vous
qui m'avez posé la question et la
deuxème expérience ne peut pas être
négligée c'est celle de la
résistance je me suis trouvé évadé de
guerre car je me suis évadé plusieurs
fois j'ai bien fini par réussir et fin
1941 en France
occupée j'ai effectué un certain un
certain nombre de missions pour la
résistance j'étais tout naturellement un
hors la loi évadé de guerre cela m'a
amené à rencontrer le général de Gaulle
qui a bien voulu me recevoir au début de
décembre 1943 à Alger il n pas toujours
été opposant à de Gaulle alors jeavais
pas toujours été opposant à de Gaulle
quand de Gaulle était le chef de la
résistance et le mainteneur de la France
je me suis séparé de lui quand il est
devenu le chef d'un parti et d'un parti
de droite c'est-à-dire qu'il ne
correspondait pas à mes opinions
politiques aux alentours de 1947 et
voilà c'est tout seulement la résistance
m'a appris ce ce que c'était que la
solidarité pour la l'indépendance
nationale et je suis resté également
très fidèle à ce
souvenir la trisème partie de votre vie
si je peux dire et celle qui nous
intéresse le plus je crois c'est votre
vie d'homme politique vous avez été euh
sous la 4e République si M S ex vous
avez été ministre voyons de l'intérieur
vous avez été ministre je suis resté
pratiquement 7 ans au gouvernement oui
bon qu'est-ce que vous tirez comme
enseignement de cette période là et et
et en définitive quel jugement
portez-vous sur votre action d'homme à
ce moment-là j'essaie en effet souvent
de me poser la question est-ce qu'à un
moment donné de ma vie politique j'ai
été moi personnellement vraiment utile à
mon pays est-ce que j'ai détourné le
cours des choses dans la bonne direction
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
dans la plupart des cas j'étais très
jeune quand je suis entré au
gouvernement j'avais 30 ans et je n'ai
pas rempli tout de suite des postes
importants mais je retiens
essentiellement de ces longues années
d'apprentissage un événement capital
pour moi certainement et je l'espère
pour la France ça a été en 1950 et 1951
le règlement pacifique des graves
difficultés qui nous opposaent à tous
les dirigeants des peuples d'Afrique
noire à l'époque la plupart de ces
dirigeants étaient dans des prisons ou
dans des bagnes je les en ai sortis j'ai
discuté avec eux j'ai tenté de bâtir ce
que pourrait être l'amitié entre la
France et l'Afrique
noire j'ai rencontré beaucoup
d'oppositions à l'époque par exemple
tout ce qui était galiste m'accusait de
trahir de vendre l'Afrique noire au
communisme international vous imaginez
vendre l'Afrique au communisme
international alors que mon partenaire
c'était au fois de boigner le vieux sage
de Côte d'Ivoire donc bataille difficile
qui a été reprise par la suite par
divers hommes politiques qui ont rempli
qui a un rôle très juste et très utile
comme Monsieur Gaston de Fire mais
n'allons pas trop vite je crois que là
en effet j'ai pu agir sur la politique
française vous avez été également
euh féocement attaqué pendant cette
période là vous êtes probablement
l'homme politique qui a été attaqué le
plus vigoureusement et qu'on a essayé de
de compromettre du reste c'est certain
depuis 20 ans je crois que peu d'hommes
politiques ont été aussi souvent attaqué
que moi-même et avec autant de
méchanceté il reste une quand on est à
l'extérieur quelque chose de
d'irritant dans cette par là est-ce que
vous pourriez m'en parler mais
sûrement je n'ai jamais hésité à aborder
ce
problème il me suffirait pour cela de me
reporter aux grands exemples d'un George
Clémenceau qui toute sa vie dû souffrir
de ce genre d'attaque et pour ce qui me
concerne
peut-être pensez-vous à laffaire des
fuites par exemple en réalité vous
n'ignorez pas on a su très vite qu'il
s'agissait d'une bande de filou qui
fabriquaent des faux papiers et qui
voulait se rendre intéressant mais j'en
ai souffert on en parle plus tout est
clair sur ce point peut-être l'affaire
de l'Observatoire reste-t-elle plus
obscure dans la mesure où depuis 6 ans
jamais le gouvernement ni la justice ne
m'ont donné l'occasion de m'expliquer
sur des faits tout de même qui me
concernent jamais ça a été la politique
de de la fuite devant moi je n'ai jamais
rencontré
personne mais il faut vous dire que j'ai
été ministre de l'Intérieur en
1954 avec Pierre MZ France et j'ai été
très dur implacable à l'égard de ces
bafond dont trouve trop souvent ces gens
des polices
parallèles qui croi un peu que la France
est un pays conquis Onon peut exercer
les pires métiers l'enlèvement récent de
monsieur benbka a dû vous éclairer sur
ce genre d'exploit je les ai frappé ils
ont tendu leur guetapan et comme ils ont
rencontré la complaisance de certains
milieux politique auquel je mepposais
avec fermeté peut-être même avec
violence et bien la combinaison s'est
faite et l'on a tenté de me compromettre
dès le premier jour j'ai dit c'est une
Mach tion et dans le fond aujourd'hui je
vous en parle rien ne trouble non pas
mon indifférence mais ma sérénité et
s'il advenait qu'on en reparle j'en
serais heureux car je crois qu'il me
serait aisé
désormais de faire la démonstration
qu'on me refuse voyez-vous je vous ai
parlé de mon enfance de ma
famille nous sommes depuis toujours au
même endroit je suis député de la niève
depuis 19 ans je n'ai perdu je n'ai
perdu l'amitié d'aucun de mes parents
l'estime d'aucun de mes amis cela me
suffit si vous voulez je voudrais que
nous en arrivions maintenant
aujourd'hui
comment pour un homme qui se décide à
présenter sa candidature à la présidence
de la République c'est-à-dire au poste
suprême c'est quand même un acte
important il faut'en sentir à la fois la
stature et en même
temps j'aimerais bien que vousiez
comment vous avez été amené à présenter
cette candidature vous m'riez posé cette
question au mois de juin dernier je vous
a dit je ne Seris pas candidat pendant
plus d'un an j'ai soutenu totalement la
candidature de Monsieur Gaston de fer je
pensais qu'il ferait un bon Président de
la République car c'est un grand
administrateur et un homme de caractère
je n'épousais pas exactement son analyse
politique je souhaitais que la gauche
puusse rassembler mais je pensais que le
devoir premier d'un républicain c'était
d'être discipliné de chercher l'unité de
s'entendre pour gagner ensemble une
victoire absolument
nécessaire quand monsieur Gachon de fer
s'est retiré je ne pouvais pas non plus
prévoir la suite mais lorsque au début
de septembre de cette année j'ai vu la
carence de la gauche les querelles
l'incertitude et je crois d'une certaine
manière le désarroi de l'opinion alors
j'ai décidé de me
présenter pourquoi sans doute il y
avait-il d'autres candidats aussi
qualifiés que moi mais il fallait bien
que quelqu'un avant ça pris ses
responsabilités je l'ai fait quand vous
êtes présenté vous n'étiez pas à ce
moment-là le candidat unique de la
gauche vous étiez François mitteron
j'étais candidat tout seul sans doute
correspondais-je à
une hypothèse politique j'avais quand
même réfléchi médité dans les jours qui
précédaient et je savais que si je
faisais des propositions précises
concrètes si je dessinais des
orientations politiques et bien tout ce
qui était responsable dans la gauche
tout ce qui compte se regrouperer parce
que cela correspond au vœux profond du
peuple que nous représentons bon
d'accord mais euh si vous voulez je
crois qu'il faut en arriver à aux
définitions est-ce que le mot gauche
encore un sens aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
ça qu'est-ce que ça veut bien pouvoir
dire gauche en 1965 vous me permettez
quand même de revenir en arrière oui et
bien en
1789 la gauche c'était tout ce qui se
battait pour les libertés
individuelles pour la justice pour
l'égalité
sociale en
1848 ce qui se battaaiit pour que des
enfants de 10 ans travaillent moins de
12 he par jour c'était la gauche et
pendant ce temps la droite crayit à tout
tête qu'on allait détruire les
fondements de la société en
1936 quand Léon Blom a dirigé le
gouvernement de Front populaire
qu'est-ce que c'était que la gauche
sinon les congés payés la semaine de 40
he et bien d'autres choses et à l'époque
leurs adversaires expliquaient encore
une fois que la société allait
s'écrouler bien en
1965 nous avons en effet à définir nos
objectifs sans doute la ligne de départ
a changé nous devons être de notre
époque et nous devons aussi tenir compte
des des conquêtes que nous avons
rapporté nous de la gauche en 1965 je
crois que une définition stricte d'une
politique de revenue d'expansion
économique de meilleure répartition du
profit entre ceux qui à l'heure actuelle
sont encore des privilégiés et l'immense
masse des producteurs et des
travailleurs je crois qu'une défense
acharnée de la paix en particulier en
luttant contre la dissémination de
l'arme nucléaire et donc contre la force
de frappe je crois que une lutte
acharnée pour le désarmement et pour la
coexistence pacifique je crois que ce
sont des finalités de gauche la gauche
voyez-vous cherche d'abord la justice et
veut que la justice établisse un nouvel
ordre la droite elle elle veut que elle
veut l'ordre elle veut que la justice
garantisse l'ordre c'est toute la
différence bien nous hommes de gauche de
1965 il faut ignorer aucun problème
jusqu'à celui de N au villes embouteillé
qui
emprisonne l'homme dans une sorte de de
carcan dont il ne peut sortir notre
objectif nous c'est le bien-être et le
bonheur de l'homme mais nous ne sommes
pas des naïfs et nous savons qu'il faut
structurer et diriger et organiser la
société sans quoi nous la laissons à
l'abandon ou plutôt nous la laissons
dans la propriété des grands groupes
financiers de la haute finance des
monopoles qui ont pour objectif quelqu
quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir avec
ce que nous désirons nous la Gauche
moderne c'est simplement la connaissance
par les moyens de la science de la
technique de la statistique de ce que
doit être le le monde dans 10 ans et il
faut préparer ces 10 années-là et aussi
la suite la droite elle est portée dans
un rêve du passé elle cherche à
maintenir à tout prix elle sagripe au
passé voilà ce qui nous différencie
encore vous pardonnerez la rapidité de
cette réponse qui mériterait de plus en
plus explications je c pourrais les
donner peut-être dans d'autres je ne
manquerai pas de le faire mais enfin
malgré tout ce sont des définitions un
peu théoriques si vous me permettez euh
la gauche c'est aussi quand même un
certain nombre de partis et il semble
que lorsque vous avez annoncé votre
candidature que le raliment de s parti
un candidat unique de la gauche qui
paraît un peu miraculeux soit pas fait
tout seul quand même soit pas fait sans
mal on l'a dit mais ce n'est pas
exact je me suis déclaré au début du
mois de
septembre j'ai défini mes options mes
propositions donc j'ai fixé
l'orientation les engagements sur
lesquels nous inviterions les masses à
nous choisir plutôt que le général de
Gaulle les organisations politiques qui
me soutiennent qui se sont rallé à ma
candidature en ont débattu librement ont
analysé librement la situation politique
je n'ai qu'un moment participé à ces
délibération et à ces discussions nous
avons donc passé une sorte de contrat
moral qui me laisse totalement maître de
la définition des perspectives dans les
limites de la correction que je dois à
ceux qui me suivent et non pas dans la
limite de je ne sais quelle discussion
de 10e ordre je vais aborder le 5
décembre prochain avec une entière
responsabilité et je n'ai pas de proche
à faire aux organisations politiques
leur loyauté a été entière et je sais
qu'aujourd'hui ils se battent tout
autour de moi pour entraîner les
millions et les millions de Françaises
et de Français qui n'appartiennent à
aucun parti politique mais qui se
reconnaissent dans la gauche pour que
cette masse immense participe au
puissant courant populaire qui se
dessine aujourd'hui oui mais euh on se
pose également le problème de où
commence et où finit la gauche et quand
je dis fini la gauche euh ça pose
également le problème du Parti
communiste qui je crois est aussi un
problème important je me rappelle d'une
période qui n'est pas tellement
lointaine où certains hommes politiques
de gauche disaient le Parti communiste
n'est pas n'est pas à gauche il est à
l'Est bon c'estàd que il y a quand même
on a dit ça en effet oui bon et bien
est-ce que ce problème du Parti
communiste n'a pas effrayé ou donner
envie de fuir un certain nombre un
certain nombre d'autres personnes vous
savez ceux qui ont fui avaient déjà
décidé de fuir l'épouvantail communiste
l'homme au couteau entre les dents tout
ça ça fait partie des vieilles lunes il
est certain que le Parti communiste avec
son idéologie sa doctrine sa hiérarchie
représente un tout homogène et que on a
le droit de ne pas être d'accord avec
l'ensemble de ces perspectives c'est
d'ailleurs mon
cas ce que je
considère c'est que le Parti communiste
représente des millions de
travailleurs et que il s'est engagé
loyalement dans son soutien à monégard
et qu'est-ce que vous voulez beaucoup de
ceux qui font aujourd'hui la
finbouche ne dois jamais oublier que moi
après tout lorsque je me trouve dans ma
mairie de châteaufinon dans la niève je
sais qu'il y a 300 m de là des usines où
l'on travaille dur je sais qu'il y a
tout autour de cette petite ville le
Morvant les agriculteurs souvent
communistes connaissent les épreuves le
travail extrêmement ardu et bien moi je
préfère avoir cet ouvrier ce paysan là
qu'un certain nombre de gens dont je
n'ai pas besoin même sil communiste
voyez-v je préfère cet ouvrier et ce
paysan qui se sent aujourd'hui emporté
dans l'élan de toute une gauche où l'on
sent que la victoire est pour demain que
c'est possible et on y
cro il faut bien que vous rendez compte
monsieur ROG Louis que
nous sommes très loin des querelles des
partis pris il y a 20
ans il y a eu trois grandes
circonstances historiqu où les
communistes ont été associés à la
reconstruction nationale d'abord avec
léonblom en 1936 c'était le Front
populaire ensuite en
1945 pour la reconstruction de la France
libérée avec le général de Gaulle qui
était encore le chef de la résistance et
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure pas
encore le chef d'un parti politique de
droite et bien la troisème circonstance
c'est celle-ci et je me réjouis moi oui
je me réjouis de les avoir tous autour
de
moi pourquoi faire pourquoi faire car il
est évident aussi que le problème le
plus important qu'on se pose et d'accord
la
victoire constituera
euh si intervient le le 5 décembre
prochain euh un acte négatif
d'abord très positif bon vous appelez
positif mais pour faire quoi et que se
passera-t-il
après vous avez raison de poser cette
question c'est celle de la stabilité
politique il me semble oui bien sûr car
il y a de mauvais souvenir quand même
voyez-vous le choix à
faire il est entre le général de GA et
moi moi en tant que
représentant des forces populaires des
républicaines de progrès qui représente
nul n'en doute des millions de
suffrages si c'était moi qui vous
interrogeais je vous diraiis et avec le
général de Gaulle vous êtes bien sûr de
votre
stabilité un homme qui a eu 7 ans de
pouvoir aujourd'hui frappé par les
athèes de l'âge et qui n'offre rien
puisque lui-même dit si je par il y a
plus rien c'est néant ça c'est la
stabilité tandis que tout un peuple qui
se reconnaît qui est content de se
reconnaître tous ces gens qui marchent
au coude à coude qui sont passés
par-dessus leurs disputes qui savent que
la gauche ça existe c'est vivant que la
gauche va conquérir à nouveau le pouvoir
en restant bien enraciné dans le peuple
alors vous estimez que ce n'est pas la
stabilité non parce que vous avez besoin
que je vous parle peut-être des
institutions bien les institutions je
l'ai déclaré
déjà
solennellement sauf pour ce qui concerne
l'article 16 qui donne en fait des
pouvoirs dictatoriaux au président de la
République aucun des articles qui touche
à la stabilité du pouvoir exécutif du
gouvernement ne sera modifié je
l'appliquerai loyalement le peuple
français l'a voté c'est comme
ça lorsque je serai président de la
République si je le suis je demanderai
aux formations politiques
majoritaire de passer un solennel
contrat de gouvernement
et d'ailleurs s'il y en autre que moi et
président de la République le Général de
Gaulle par exemple comment fera-t-il en
1967 il sera obligé de faire comme moi
il aura une majorité politique qui sera
peut-être différente de celle
d'aujourd'hui et il faudra bien qu'il
examine ce problème sérieusement et il
n'est pas certain qu'il pourra imposer
ses vues ou bien ce sera une crise grave
et bien moi j'examinerai le problème tel
que le suffrage universel me le propose
aura dans des lettres dans des dé les
très rapides puisque élu président de la
République je dissoudrai l'Assemblée
nationale alors là intervient un
problème d'homme
ou bien j'aurai avec moi ce courant
populaire qui conduira une nouvelle
majorité au Parlement et j'imposerai
dans le cadre de la Constitution
actuelle sur le plan qui nous occupe
j'imposerai des règles absolues
j'arbitrerai je serai la caution de la
stabilité parce que moi jamais je
n'accepteraiis de revoir le spectacle de
1958 jamais je
n'accepterai voir les républicains
défaire eux-mêmes leur
République j'imposerai oui par les
moyens qui me seront donnés légalement
j'imposerai la stabilité politique mais
pour peu que les grandes formations
politiques n'est pas tiré comme je l'ai
fait moi-même les conclusions des
événements qui se sont produits depuis
10 ans et je suis convaincu voyez-vous
que vous êtes devant une gauche nouvelle
je suis convaincu que vous avez devant
vous des citoyens qui désirent réussir
pour la France et pour le peuple ce que
nous avons entrepris et ce que j'ai
ressenti depuis le 9 septembre ne peut
que me confirmer dans ce qui est une
certitude bon mais je crois qu'il nous
reste 2 minutes mais je vais en profiter
pour vous poser une question un peu
venimeuse sur la fin si vous voulez que
je tire d'un souvenir le souvenir d'une
interview d'un chef d'État euh
récemment accéderé à l'indépendance et
qui m'a dit lorsque j'ai demandé
l'indépendance je m'attendais à ce qu'on
me la donne dans 5 ans et j'ai été
terrifié lorsqu'on me l'a donné tout de
suite et je sentais venir le
Cho est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un peu de
cela dans l'attitude actuelle de la
gauche
justement et bien je n'aurais pas besoin
de plus de quelques secondes pour vous
répondre en conscience ou en
conscience je crois pouvoir dire et la
gauche avec moi que nous sommes prêts à
assumer notre
responsabilité